l'homme lui même pourrait bien être
responsable de certaines dégradations
climatiques depuis le 19e siècle une
quantité chaque jour croissante de
charbon et d'hydrocarbures et brûlées
dans le monde cette opération abouti à
la libération de quantités énormes de
gaz carbonique
quelques 20 milliards de tonnes par an
actuellement
la quantité globale de gaz carbonique
présentes dans l'atmosphère augmente
donc de façon sensible malgré la
présence des océans et de la végétation
qui en absorbent une fraction
appréciable
ainsi la teneur de l'air en gaz
carbonique qui n'était que de 290
parties par millions à la fin du siècle
dernier est aujourd'hui de l'ordre de
330 parties par millions et pourrait
atteindre 400 parties par million vers
l'an 2010 si la consommation de charbon
et de pétrole garde le même rythme
aujourd'hui dans les années à venir
cette augmentation est assez
préoccupante
en effet le gaz carbonique présent dans
l'atmosphère possède la propriété
d'absorber les radiations infrarouges
émises par le globe terrestre
et lorsque la proportion de gaz
carbonique dans l'air s'accroît une plus
grande partie des radiations terrestre
est absorbé ce qui entraîne une
augmentation de la température
le processus est analogue à celui qui se
déroule dans une serre les vitres de
celle ci laisse passer les radiations
visible du soleil qui chauffent le sol
mais ces mêmes vitres retiennent les
radiations infrarouges émises par le sol
et la température s'élève à l'intérieur
de la serre un autre facteur dû aux
activités humaines joue également dans
le sens d'une élévation moyenne de la
température du globe les diverses
sources d'énergie inhérentes à la
civilisation industrielle produisent une
quantité chacun est croissante de
chaleur dont une bonne partie se répand
dans l'air ou dans l'eau
s'il était difficile d'estimer la
quantité d'énergie ainsi perdu en
revanche on connaît approximativement la
quantité d'énergie produite par l'homme
selon une étude menée par l'institut de
technologie du massachusetts
en 1970 la quantité d'énergie artificiel
fabriqué par une grande ville
industrielle était égal à l'énergie
reçue du soleil par cette ville pour
l'ensemble de la terre la quantité
d'énergie produite par l'homme serait
seulement 1000 fois plus petite que
celle reçue du soleil mais elles
augmentent de 3% par an enfin il est
probable que la mise en valeur des
terres incultes le défrichement
l'urbanisation ont aussi eu une
incidence sur le climat ne serait ce que
parce qu'ils modifient le pouvoir
réfléchissant de grandes étendues de
terrain il est donc possible qu'une
augmentation de la température moyenne
de l'atmosphère soit à craindre
s'il y avait un réchauffement ce
réchauffement actuel
enfin le réchauffement que l'on pourrait
envisager sera réchauffement très faible
ce serait soit réchauffement d'origine
naturelle ce serait aussi de l'ordre de
quelques dixièmes de degrés soit un
réchauffement artificielle provoquée par
les activités humaines
ce serait du même ordre de grandeur
mettons que l'on aille jusqu'à 1 degré
les conséquences seraient à peine
perceptible mais supposons qu'un
réchauffement de 3 à 5 degrés se
produisent que se passerait-il alors et
c'est difficile à prévoir
objectivement femmes supposons qu'un tel
réchauffement se produise il y aurait
fusion d'une partie de la calotte
glaciaire peut-être même disparition
totale des glaces au pôle nord car on
changerait que le bilan énergétique du
fait de la disparition temporaire des
glaces il aurait une augmentation du
niveau
des océans en particulier de combien je
ne peux pas faire le calcul de tête
comme ça mais il est probable que les
terres basses les rivages des océans
seraient recouverts par les eaux
mais ans de l'activité humaine sur le
climat réchauffement ou refroidissement
de la terre bien des hypothèses
contradictoires ont été avancés et
l'opinion publique s'interroge moi je
crois une chose que depuis il ya tout ce
qu'ils veulent on m a qui ont un petit
trapu le temps je ne sais pas s'il n'y a
pas quelque chose de là haut qui nous a
un petit peu chamboulée depuis je crois
qu'on a fait des expériences dans le
cosmo là je crois qu'il ya quelque chose
déranger ou bien alors il ya ainsi que
l'on que nous n'avons pas connu l'avant
cycle de maintenant tout le monde nous
dit ac c'est un peu la bomba taille de
l'enfant moi j'ai 30 ans passe est un
peu peut-être façon générale la dalle
qui se réchauffe qui sont refroidis
l'organisation météorologique mondiale
cette année d'ailleurs a ressenti le
besoin de remettre les choses en place
car il y avait eu des déclarations assez
spectaculaire qui avait été enfin
présenté et largement diffusées
d'ailleurs par la parole à la presse
mondiale et on pouvait s'inquiéter de
ces des conclusions de ces déclarations
aussi de l'organisation météorologique
mondiale at elle tenu à affirmer que
actuellement il n'y avait véritablement
aucun moyen de savoir à court terme
c'est-à-dire à échéance de quelques
décennies ou d'un siècle ou deux même de
savoir si le climat allait évoluer dans
un sens et dans ou dans l'autre s'il ne
peut encore prévoir l'évolution du
climat
l'homme doit-il pour autant se résigner
à en subir les effets le peut-il
envisager de le modifier volontairement
toujours en avance sur son temps et même
sur le nôtre jules verne évoqué cette
possibilité dans un roman intitulé sens
dessus dessous
dans le cerveau d'un savant illuminé
avait germé l'idée de redresser la kz
des pôles terrestres
ceci dans le but de faire fondre les
masses classe hier du pôle nord afin
d'exploiter commodément les gisements de
charbon et autres minerais qui s'y
trouvent
l'explosion d'un gigantesque canaux
enfouis dans le kilimandjaro devait
théoriquement provoqué ce changement de
position de la terre par rapport au
soleil
aujourd'hui faire fondre les glaces des
pôles n'est plus tout à fait de la
science fiction
n'at-on pas avancé récemment l'hypothèse
selon laquelle le climat de l'hémisphère
nord pourrait être rendue plus du tout
si l'on fondait la calotte glaciaire du
groenland en répandant à sa surface une
couche de poussière de charbon
ceux ci auraient en effet pour résultat
d'augmenter l'absorption du rayonnement
solaire par le sol la lutte contre les
cyclones fait également partie des
préoccupations actuelles
pourra-t-on un jour les détruira temps
ou du moins dévier leurs trajectoires
certains pensent qu'on le peut déjà
puisque en 1975 des américains ont été
accusés d'avoir détourné l'ouragan fifi
qui s'est abattue sur le honduras alors
que d'après les calculs de certains
spécialistes
il aurait dû dévasté les plages de
floride en pleine saison estivale
alors pourquoi ne pas penser que cette
technologie pourrait aboutir à des
utilisations belliqueuse par exemple à
l'aide de fusées porteuses de certains
produits chimiques
on pourrait créer des lucarnes dans la
couche d'ozone de la stratosphère
dès lors les rayons nocifs du soleil ne
serait plus arrêtée par l'ozone et cela
entraînerait pour les populations des
territoires situés sous cette lucarne
des risques de brûlures de la peau et de
maladies mortelles en faisant exploser
des bombes de grandes puissances à
certains endroits critiques des failles
qui traverse le globe
on pourrait théoriquement provoquer des
tremblements de terre à des milliers de
kilomètres de l'endroit où aurait eu
lieu l'explosion
on devine l'intérêt stratégique que ces
procédés pourrait soulever chez
certaines puissances irresponsable de
tels projets sont heureusement
passablement utopique en outre de telles
actions pourraient provoquer des
modifications climatiques ce inattendu
éventuellement catastrophique pour le
monde entier la guerre climatique
suppose des actions sur le climat c'est
à dire sur de très grandes l'échelle des
espaces voir de temps alors je crois que
à cet égard il y as peut-être à craindre
pour le grand futur il est possible
qu'on sache échéance déréglé
l'atmosphère en introduisant quelques
grains de sable dans la circulation
générale
mais ceci me paraît très lointain est en
tout cas la notion de guerre
météorologiques ne l'est pas concevable
et peu concevable dans un avenir
rapproché et c'est tant mieux bien
entendu il ne fait aucun doute que la
répartition actuelle des climats du
globe ne représente qu'à l'état
d'équilibré temporaire le climat de la
terre se modifiera demain comme il s'est
modifié hier
tout le problème est de savoir dans quel
sens va se produire l'évolution les
spécialistes qui se hasardent à formuler
des prévisions sont loin d'être d'accord
entre eux selon les facteurs auquel on
accorde une importance prédominante
on peut en effet dans l'état actuel des
connaissances aussi bien prédire pour
les siècles à venir un lent retour à un
régime glaciaire qu'un réchauffement
général de la terre tout ce qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'il est probable que le
réchauffement interglaciaire qui règne
depuis quelques 8000 ans aboutira
finalement à un régime glaciaire plus
froid mais ce changement s'est il déjà
amorcé
s'amorce est il aujourd'hui d'une
manière quasi imperceptible ou bien sa
mort sera-t-il demain et alors
dans combien de siècles ou deux
millénaires c'est l'un des nombreux
mystères de la terre qui restent à
élucider
[Musique]